when you implement back-propagation for
your neural network you need to really
compute the slope or the derivative of
the activation functions so let's take a
look at our choices of activation
functions and how you can compute the
slope of these functions can see
familiar sigmoid activation function and
so for any given value of Z maybe this
value of z this function will have some
slope or some derivative corresponding
to if you draw a rule line there
you know the height over width of this
little triangle here so if G of Z is the
sigmoid function then the slope of the
function is d DZ G of Z and so we know
from calculus that this is the slope of
G of X and Z and if you are familiar
with calculus and know how to take
derivatives if you take the derivative
of the sigmoid function it is possible
to show that it is equal to this formula
and again I'm not going to do the
calculus steps but if you're familiar
with calculus feel free to pause the
video and try to prove this yourself
and so this is equal to just G of Z
times 1 minus G of Z so let's just
sanity check that this expression makes
sense
first if Z is very large so say Z is
equal to 10 then G of Z will be close to
1 and so the form that we have on the
Left tells us that D DZ G of Z does be
close to G of Z which is equal to 1
times 1 minus 1 which is therefore very
close to 0 and this isn't D correct
because when Z is very launched the
slope is close to 0 conversely of Z is
equal to minus 10 so there's no way out
there then G of Z is close to 0
so the following on the left tells us d
DZ G of Z will be close to G of Z which
is 0 times 1 line is 0 and so it is also
very close to 0 or Sakura
finally a Z is equal to zero then G of Z
is equal to one-half as a sigmoid
function right here and so the
derivative is on equal to 1/2 times 1
minus 1/2 which is equal to 1/4 and that
actually is turns out to be the correct
value of the derivative or the slope of
this function when Z is equal to 0
finally just to introduce one more piece
of notation sometimes instead of writing
this thing the shorthand for the
derivative is G prime of Z so G prime of
Z in calculus the the little dash on top
is called time because of G prime of Z
is a shorthand for the in calculus for
the derivative of the function of G with
respect to the input variable Z um and
then in a neural network we have a
equals G of Z right equals this then
this formula also simplifies to a times
1 minus a so sometimes the
implementation you might see something
like G prime of Z equals a times 1 minus
a and that just refers to you know the
observation that G prime which is means
derivative is equal to this over here
and the advantage of this formula is
that if you've already computed the
value for a then by using this
expression you can very quickly compute
the value for the slope for G prime s
all right so that was the sigmoid
activation function let's now look at
the Technic activation function similar
to what we had previously the definition
of d DZ G of Z is the slope of G of Z at
a particular point of Z and if you look
at the formula for the hyperbolic
tangent function on any of you know
calculus you can take derivatives and
show that this simplifies to this
formula
and using the own shorthand we had
previously when we call this G prime of
Z you gain so if you want you can sanity
check that this formula make sense so
for example if Z is equal to 10 10 H of
Z will be very close to 1 this goes from
plus 1 to minus 1 and then G prime of Z
according to this formula will be about
1 minus 1 squared so terms are equal to
0 so that was a Z is very large
the slope is close to zero conversely a
Z is very small say Z is equal to minus
10 then 10 H of Z will be close to minus
1 and so G prime of Z will be close to 1
minus negative 1 squared so it's close
to 1 minus 1 which is also close to 0
and finally is equal to 0 then 10 H of Z
is equal to 0 and then the slope is
actually equal to 1 which is we selected
a slope point um z is equal to 0 so just
to summarize if a is equal to G of Z so
if a is equal to this channel Z then the
derivative G prime of Z is equal to 1
minus a squared so once again if you've
already computed the value of a you can
use this formula to very quickly compute
the derivative as well finally here's
how you compute the derivatives for the
value and leakey relu activation
functions for the value g of z is equal
to max of 0 comma Z so the derivative is
equal to you turns out to be 0 if Z is
less than 0 and 1 if Z is greater than 0
and is actually our undefined
technically undefined as V is equal to
exactly 0 but um if you're implementing
this in software it might not be a
hundred percent mathematic correct but I
work just fine if you it's V is exactly
really zero if you set the derivative
equal to 1 or decide to be zero it kind
of doesn't matter if you're a Nixon of
Malaysian technically G prime then
becomes what's called a sub gradient of
the activation function G of Z which is
why gradient descent still works but you
can think of it as that the chance of Z
being you know zero point exactly zero
zero zero is so small that it almost
doesn't matter what you set the
derivative to be equal to when Z is
equal to zero so in practice this is
what people implement for the derivative
of Z and finally if you are trading on
your own network with the we here a Luo
activation function then G of Z is going
to be max of say 0.01 Z comma Z and so G
prime of Z is equal to 0.01 if Z is less
than zero and 1 if Z is greater than
zero and once again the gradient is
technically not defined when Z is
exactly equal to zero but if you
implement a piece of code that sets the
derivative or the essentially Prime's
either a zero point zero one or two one
either way it doesn't really matter when
Z is exactly zero your co-workers so
arms of these formulas you should either
compute the slopes or the derivatives of
your activation assumptions now we have
this building blocks you're ready to see
how to implement gradient descent for
your neural network let's go into the
next videos you see that